on démarre par guillaume genton qui
dénonce mme jamain castaldi castany pour
faire des économies avant les fêtes il
aurait revendu une des vestes de baba
sur vintage c'est une baisse qui l'a
pris dans votre loge et qu'ils
apportaient leur deuxième pays à deux
semaines c'est vrai mais oui c'est vrai
alors c'est celle annoncée regardez
c'est vrai nom marc est mais c'est le
cas d'asthme et non mais dissipée par
séries loeb arrête mais sûr qu'après
m'en fais ça évidemment atta mais
j'étais obligé il fallait que je teste
un petit peu si vous étiez vraiment
populaire jeu des vendus en fait très
très vite non la wii ag ur fabrique 2
minutes et un des bandits il a vraiment
fait sa table rase et goussé fait 185
euros non non ça c'est sympa aussi un
rien et j'avais eu plusieurs scieries et
moi
tous les amis et j'avais donné une note
d'ailleurs que j'aime bientôt bande qui
daterait pas oui absolument vous voyez
pas quand les bouchons et en fait c'est
une très belle veste bombers ce
camouflage ah ouais ouais vous êtes à
c'est la vérité
je n'ai jamais tu les payes ces gens là
aussi
pour l'entente
mathieu a encore dit aux gens dont tu
dénonces matthieu delormeau mathieu
déclare à qui veut l'entendre si lille
et moi c'est la même chose aujourd'hui
il anime je suis chroniqueur de deux ans
ce sera sûrement l' inverse on est de la
même trempe
[Rires]
j'ai entendu ces horloges j'ai fait mon
travail de journaliste j'ai rapporté ses
propos il a exactement 10 à
gérer que c d of c'est d'accord c'est
d'ailleurs m trompe il a dit ce sera mon
petit c'est parce que j'ai déjà dit que
si un jour vous glissiez dans l'escalier
ce que je ne souhaite pas
je pense que le seul sur la chaîne qui
pourrait vous remplacez c'est moi
d'accord que quelqu'un quelque chose de
contredire même niveau que les vicois la
chaîne bon alors donc on sait voilà que
la chaîne fermera pas
merci aux téléspectateurs d'avoir
qu'elle a une dernière ici jean paul
dietrich prête attention à delphine a
fait une scène de jalousie à guillaume
par rapport à la révélation de gilles
verdez sur la chambre d'hôtel louée à
genève qu'est ce que c'est que ça soit
encore une tendance ici parce que vous
allez en 6 ici parce qu'il paraît
guillaume avait pris une chambre d'hôtel
à genève avec nous a pas dit timide
jeune fille parce que j'avais fait
c'était un petit peu énervé le fil du
temps à des ripailles la jeune manon
mais c'est cette histoire de montagne
non non non pas du tout
je suis allé à genève effectivement mais
c'est pas moi qu'il ya dix ans qui a
balancé cegid sa came annoncé par mois
pour une semaine
c'est quelqu'un qui déambulait dans les
couloirs c'est ma vision affiche nous
étudierions quelqu'un qui déambulait
d'un coup là on est sûr que c'est pas
isabelle
[Rires]
pour moi comme ça on enlève des gens
c'est important je sais que delphine
essaie de reconquérir j'ai eu plusieurs
appels pendant les vacances c'était des
numéros inconnus mais je suis sûr que
c'était
ok attention ici à connaître ton budget
hôtel parentois ici moi j'aimerais bien
connaître son budget tous
allés à la supercoupe qui çà ou là
dernièrement
garder lé thon rouge voilà delphine est
venu accompagné de roger en loge
ouais
là je la découvre
ça à faire couler énormément d'encre
roger c'est le couillon compagne hand de
fil au quai oui s'appelle roger ici
présentes oui oui s'appelle roger et
alors c'est un prénom john c'était
ça reviendra à la main dedans donc alors
que décidé voilà j'ai très bien j'ai
tout le monde n'a pas la chance de
s'appeler libye l'ucm asie dernièrement
delphine vous êtes venu avec roger oui
tout à fait accompagné de roger donc aux
loges car son chéri que j'embrasse que
j'adore roger aurait fait une crise de
jalousie en expliquant je n'ai aucune
confiance en benjamin castaldi guillaume
genton les clips de tpm ps vrai delphine
alors non alors c'était un genre c'est
vrai déjà construit alors non comme
maintenant alors c'était avant les
vacances il est effectivement venu avec
moi ben non pas ça faisait longtemps
kiki qui n'était plus venu et voulait
tous vous voir et c'est vrai que du coup
faire une petite mise au point avec
certaines personnes ça pouvait être
sympathique mais moi je n'ai rien fait
ouais ouais il a dit qu'il n'a aucune
confiance en moi ouais franchement il a
raison
c'est
je dois confirmer la crise conjugale et
ça a été assez chaud c'est vrai que
roger était à la fois meurtrier amer et
il avait besoin d'experts qui l'avait
pris pour
le gars et tu vas manger quoi ces
projets il n'a pas eu toutes les
explications oui je pense qu'il est
parti un peu rasséréné à tort mais les
rennais
mais alors ça va mieux c'est vrai que
ces derniers ces dernières semaines on
avait un peu traverser une crise de
couple n'en vrai aussi c'est vrai que
sur la torah et du coup vu que c'était
effectivement mon anniv et que je vous
ai demandé hier un cadeau un voyage et
que entre temps bas vous m'avez pas
encore envoyé les billets eh ben j'ai
pris l'initiative il ya une heure de
nous prendre de billet pour partir en
vacances donc je pars dans une semaine
non voilà où étaient présents vous en
avez rien à [ __ ]
du coup voilà c'est enfin vous comprenez
quoi ah mais attendez c'est à dire que
partira quand
je vais vous expliquer l'arrêt groupes
armés on ne revient
c'est comme en boîte
douglas exceptionnel c'est pour mon
c'est pour mes 30 ans vous verrez ce
sera exceptionnel tiré dans l'émission
pourrait considérer votre votre
participation à l'émission suit sera
exceptionnel d'ailleurs au m
on mettra avec la participation
extrêmement viendrait pas souvent faudra
qu'on voit quand même ses vacances à
aller roger delphine encore aurait
demandé à bernard montiel de les
conseiller pour les aider à régler leurs
problèmes intimes c'est gilbert ned
kelly est vrai aussi c'est
gilles auquel ils ont trouvé que bernard
montiel leur couple allait dans le mur
un conseiller conjugal est la mienne il
était caché dans un couloir et j'ai
entendu c'est là qu'elle soit et c'est
vrai que c'était vraiment compliqué il
était caché dans un couloir avant il par
exemple et on en est quoi
oui et donc ils ont demandé à bernard ce
qu'il pouvait faire et ce qu'il avait
une certaine expérience bernard pourra
confirmer et bernard à la fin a dit je
pense qu'à ce niveau de conflit entre
vous il n'ya que cyril qui puisse régler
ça je ne sais pas dit si bien la voir en
quoi merci bien il va si mal que ça nous
coupe les ballons non c'était juste très
amical et chaleureux je suis un homme de
sagesse comme sur cv et donc en tout cas
sa gueule quoi
une très grande intelligence comme
chacun sait est le méta j'aime est en
cours et tu fais
d'abord j'apprécie énormément roger qui
est un garçon formidable qualifieront
profil mende est amoureux d'elle et donc
voila
voila merci attention je passais ça je
te mets toi tu es toujours sympa avec
moi c'est une vraie mamie tu peux me
suis sentie foot tu sois là on sent
un visa il achetait aussi de demander
des conseils beauté m'a porté chance ah
ouais bah écoutez c'est bien la première
fois
les cherry a tous là
mazarin castaldi ça a été recalé d'une
publicité pour interflora
[Rires]
la photo n'a pas été jugée convaincante
par le client qu'est ce que c'est que
cette histoire c'est que d'avoir la
photo
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
des prochaines étapes
et l'écho est fan de jardinage pourra
confirmer
[Rires]
et si jamais la mecque fait toi le le
vapo tatouage aime les brawngp est
électrique
j'aimais pire
est-ce que jordi l'on peut venir la vie
et
la mettre en rayon s'il vous plaît s'il
vous plaît merci j'en fais deux
dernières après j'ai du boulot ou la
juste avant noël mathieu a présenté la
régie de tpm perd son neveu pour se
faire bien voir il a su lui et tous les
techniciens mais ne connaissait aucun
prénom même pas celui du réalisateur
c'est vrai c'est pas vrai je connais
tous arrête fait toujours les voir alors
c'est
donner le prénom la jeune fille voilà
qui ça à l'aller charmante
tout comme
julie n'ont juste pas les rites quoi
vous une espèce est pas non plus qui
connaît le prénom allez on peut pas ça
on est des stars on n'aime pas les
genres
[Musique]
c'est normal horreurs qu'elle autour des
techniciens charmant ab
tu sais marion ma chérie
merci à nourdine dans la
vase il vient l'oreillette quoi moi sa
peine ce charmant monsieur il connaît
tous les cas
sur 10 villes jumelles je reconnais pas
une arme à ce qu est la basse et mokhtar
et oui mais c'est ma peau ma vie ces
doctrines
qu'est ce que tu crois à savoir faire
bonjour monsieur non non on se connaît
mais sirigu connaissent aucun prénom
vous êtes horrible attention ce sera la
dernière de ce soir mais c'est la plus
grave à awala
toujours pour la cohésion du groupe
tholot
isabelle est en simple
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
ça y est en scène de jean pierre
chevènement
[Rires]
la source 1
c'est gilles verdez
qui était par hasard dans un couloir
et par hasard derrière lapin
guillaume et mathieu ne se sont pas
adressé la parole les quinze premiers
jours de la saison
car mathieu est extrêmement vexés que
guillaume epu s'associent sur une boîte
puisque je rappelle que c'est pas
mettre tous ses oeufs dans n'y avait pas
je suis évêque civile en qualité de co
producteur épanouie alors je vais vous
dire une fois de plus ça prouve que
gilles verdez est un grand journaliste
vraiment à grand avec un grand g c'est
vrai car je crois que le premier jour où
je suis arrivé on a déjeuné ensemble
c'est vrai ou pas vrai mais je voulais
pas me parler quand même
manger en tout cas oui je voulais pas me
parler et on va dire on a déjeuné oui ça
veut rien dire moi je vais te révéler
une chose c'est que cyril au départ ils
voulaient s'associer avec toi et au
moment de t'appeler malheureusement il
est tombé sur un ton docte
ensuite voudrais pas remuer le couteau
dans la plaie mais tu sais un jour tu
devais faire du shopping etc cyril oui
il n'est jamais venu ouais bah ce moment
il était avec moi il m'a couvert de
cadeaux ouais
de cadeaux et de bijoux
tu as cette émission
tout le monde qui couche avec qui
jockey souple et là on n'est pas là pour
ça merci viendrai jade révélé qu
isabelle était enceinte s'il vous plaît
pas non plus tout révéler ouais série si
vous devez choisir entre les deux parce
que c'est vrai que les deux essais de
gratter un peu comme votre amitié et
détailler leurs proches de vous c'est
vraiment la bataille entre les deux
alors si vraiment les pc et sincère lui
c'est parce que tu as les boîtes de prod
voilà le jour où tu lâches vrai clash
c'est pas paquet avec cyril non
j'attends pas au cas où ils tomberaient
nous mais promis une association mais ce
que j'attends tout est prêt à manger
sainement de voilement ont été menées
quelque chose
qui se passe et vous donner les vraies
raisons mathieu parce que valérie parle
d'amitié et là on rigole moins c'est du
business donc c'est vrai que cyril à un
moment c'est didier guillaume ou mathieu
il a réfléchi il a étudié les deux
sociétés voulait le verdict voilà
pourquoi il vous a pas pris manque de
projets créatifs de votre société
manque de perspectives à court moyen et
long terme et vos santé financière peut
convaincre grether
fiabilité moyenne j'ai la conclusion du
rapport
votre société c'est du vent et le vent
ça vaut zéro
bravo gilles verdez je pense qu'on a
tout dit c'est dingue au club êtes
toujours à port-au-prince
[Rires]
on